he also addressed his administration's
zero-tolerance policy that separates
migrant children from their parents
backlash is growing across the country
protesters marched in several cities
yesterday against the government's moved
to split up migrant families at the US
border with Mexico the administration
said yesterday it will open a temporary
shelter near El Paso to house a growing
number of children in government custody
Paula Reed is at the White House was
what the president said this morning
Paula good morning good morning
last month the administration made a
decision to start prosecuting people who
come here illegally before that it had
mostly been handled as a civil matter
but now parents are arrested and because
children cannot be incarcerated for
crimes they are separated from their
parents and often wind up far away from
their families illegal entry into the
United States is a crime it should be it
must be Attorney General Jeff Sessions
on Thursday defended the Trump
administration's zero-tolerance policy
for families illegally crossing the
border by citing Scripture Romans 13 -
oh baby love the government because God
is obtained ordain the government for
his purposes our policies that can
result in short term separation of
families is not unusual or unjustified
the policy has reportedly left more than
a thousand children separated from their
detained parents including about 70 at
this shelter at a former Walmart in
Brownsville Texas but there is no law
that requires the separation of families
good afternoon
we asked White House press secretary
Sarah Sanders why the administration
changed the way it handles illegal
immigration cases the laws are the ones
that have been on the books for over a
decade and the president is enforcing
them until Democrats are willing to
actually fix this problem it's going to
continue but we would like to see it
so they take responsibility for its
policy change from civil hailing the
most civil matters to criminal so he
said a policy change to enforce the law
that's been that's been that
administration's policy since the day we
got here made a decision in April that
he was gonna made some handling it has
been our administration family's power
situation said it was a deterrent our
administration has had the same position
since we started on day one that we were
going to enforce the law speaking to
reporters on the North Lawn this morning
the president said he hates taking
children away from their parents with
children being taken away from know I
hate it I hate the children being taken
away the Democrats have to change their
law that's there long as you heard right
there on the North Lawn just moments ago
the president again saying it's up to
Democrats to solve this situation even
though Republicans control both chambers
of Congress and of course the White
House but until a legislative solution
can be reached the message from the
Attorney General is that if you do not
want to be separated from your children
do not attempt to come here illegally
Paula thank you